welcome to whoops i rewrote it in rust
[Laughter]
my name is brian martin my pronouns are
he him and i'm a software engineer at
twitter
uh i've been at twitter for seven years
and have been using rust for six years
uh i've worked on a few different open
source projects at twitter
a benchmarking tool for cash performance
systems performance telemetry agent and
now i'm working on a cache server
all these projects are in rust
when i'm not at a computer i'm a
volunteer with my local search and
rescue unit and i'm training my dog
riker to find people who get lost in the
wilderness which is also a lot of fun
this talk is framed around caching
specifically distributed key value
storage
you can think of it basically as a hash
map over the network
caching is really high throughput and
very low latency we expect around 100
000 requests per second
on a single core with typical latencies
below one millisecond so very very fast
because we're just grabbing data out of
memory and pushing it over the network
we use caches to store frequently
accessed items and this helps protect
the database or backend services by
reducing the number of requests they
have to handle
so this helps particularly if you have
spikes
of traffic for frequently accessed items
you can just hold those in the cache and
then the database doesn't need to
serve those requests
this can also speed things up because
the cache tends to respond a lot faster
than a database would
so
yeah it winds up being pretty important
for distributed service
and system performance
there are a couple of common open source
solutions in this space
memcache and redis
are both written in c and tend to be
used a lot in the industry
uh but this leads me to pelican which is
twitter's uh caching framework that we
want to use to replace uh our forks of
memcache and redis
this gives us a single code base
to produce multiple caching solutions
and to easily experiment with
new things we can do in this space
and it's a lot easier to manage one code
base than have to go make changes in a
couple different forks if there's some
new feature that we want to add
so
i basically wanted to do some work on
pelican
to add some tls support so we wanted to
be able to encrypt traffic between the
client and the cache server
and
basically i was talking to my manager
yao and
we were thinking that we could probably
do this in rust uh
and add tls support that way
um so i
i i mean i personally feel a lot more
comfortable using rust than c and
particularly in this sort of space the
safety and all the nice language
benefits of rust
seemed like they'd be good
but one of the things is we wanted to
make sure that the performance matched
the c implementation
we didn't really want to take a hit in
terms of performance
there were some previous efforts that
had
made me think that doing this in rust
was going to be possible
so back in 2018 an engineer wanted to
add a new storage library to pelican and
decided to try doing it in rust
and the idea was basically to use the
core of pelican
but have an ffi wrapper around this rust
storage library and just
include that in pelican
uh so this worked out pretty well the
development was really quick
so that was kind of impressive and it
showed that having a hybrid rust and c
server was going to be workable
and this became the first commit of rust
into pelican so that was super exciting
then in 2019 we had another engineer who
was a bit more ambitious and wanted to
try using rust for the actual server
code
so they
basically decided to use tokyo which is
a async framework for rust it's a
executor and all these other things
and so they decided to use tokyo as the
server runtime but wanted to leverage
the c components
from the normal cache server so things
like storage
buffers foundational libraries
essentially
[Music]
but this was really neat it showed that
we could do a lot more advanced layering
of c and rest in the code base
and i was super excited to see that rust
could be used for a larger role in
pelican
as i mentioned before performance of
cache services is super important
very very fast service right um
and to
make sure that it's fast we need to do
performance testing you can't improve uh
what you can't measure
so typically what we do is we apply a
synthetic workload that's rate limited
and we record the latency for each
request into a hdr style histogram
and the goal is basically to get the
highest throughput that we can
with some latency bound and typically we
might define that as the p39 latency
needs to be below some number so
uh
so why p39 the 99.9 percentile that
seems like it's pretty far out in the
tail why would we worry about that
well it it seems like it wouldn't really
matter that much it's only point one
percent of your requests that are going
to see latencies
this slow or slower
but there's this thing called fan out
and we might need to make multiple
requests to the caching layer in order
to fulfill some higher level requests
so if we have a fan out of 10 meaning we
need to make 10 queries to the cache and
wait for all those to come back
about 1
of our requests
at this higher level are going to see
latencies that
meet or exceed the p39
this gets a lot worse if you have a fan
out of a hundred now 9.5 roughly of your
requests are going to see latencies this
high
and fan outs this
large aren't really that uncommon if you
think about something like loading a
home timeline or something like that
there's a lot of data that you need to
get
so the lesson here is that the tail
latencies appear a lot more often than
you would think
fano this wide isn't unusual and so we
do care about latencies way out into the
tail
okay so we had this implementation of
twim cash which is twitter memcache in
pelican
in rust from 2019
it's memcache
protocol compatible it was using tokyo
for its networking and uses the c
storage library that
was uh present in the c implementation
of of uh pelican cache so
i wanted to see if this rust server
would be a good starting point for
adding tls support
and first we need to test the
performance
and unfortunately it didn't perform as
well as this implementation throughput
was about 10 to 15 percent less
which means we'd need more instances to
serve the same aggregate qps
and the latency was about 25 to 30
percent higher at the p39 and that
wasn't going to be super great for use
in production
i might start to see timeouts and errors
and making a service 10 to 15 more
expensive is
not an easy thing to sell
and just to sort of visualize uh the
benchmarking results here we're
comparing the c implementation in blue
with the rust implementation in red and
what we're looking at here is the p39
latency
in microseconds across a range of
throughputs so basically we can
ramp what that rate limit is and trace
out this latency curve
and we do expect that as we get more and
more traffic into the server that things
are going to start backing up
some resource is going to saturate
and latency is going to go up
but here we can clearly see that the
rust implementation has worse latency
it's higher up
and it doesn't reach the same throughput
it doesn't go as far to the right hand
side of the chart
so
we can see that it's not going to
perform as well basically
but
rust is known to be pretty fast it
should be as fast as c for this we're
not really doing anything super crazy
we're just
reading data from memory and putting it
over the network
so let's see if we can make it faster by
taking a few steps back
a really basic server and sort of the
mother of all servers is this thing
called a ping server it's
a little more advanced than an echo
server maybe you could argue
but it's really simple
it knows two
different commands it knows ping and if
you send it a ping it sends back palm
and if you send it to quit it hangs up
the session
so
really basic but it has
all the components that you need
for a network service you have
connection management you have request
parsing you have response composition
you have the whole whole life cycle of
things
and you can actually make this thing
production grade
you can have all the debugging
and tracing and metrics and things that
you might want from a real network
service
so this is a really good starting point
because we can
start
thinking about the framework of things
and make sure that we have all these
pieces in place
and we can start layering in tls support
and start having plain text and
encrypted sessions being able to be
handled by this ping server
uh and since i was concerned about
making the performance match the c
implementation i wanted to try and make
things as equivalent as possible
the c implementation of the ping server
was basically just using epoll on linux
so we could use this library called mio
which is a foundational library for
tokyo
and it's basically just a nice wrapper
around epoll or whatever other
equivalent is for for osx or windows or
whatever
and
we wouldn't need to worry about like
async executor performance and all these
other really complex things
so
i was reducing the surface area of the
problem basically stepping back using
epoll
right the
kind of event handling loop myself
and it'll look a lot more like the c
version at that point and i don't need
to debug performance of tokyo and all
that stuff
so to get to a prototype quickly i
decided to use some foundational
libraries that i had been using my other
projects
and this meant that i could focus on
getting something built out quickly with
a pure rust build
and if i ran into any problems with
these libraries i was like well i can
always switch back to the c
implementations later but it's going to
be a lot easier to work with
something that's a pure rust build to to
get started
at this point i also added tls support
using boring ssl
so i could be sure that the design
accommodated the tls sessions
and then we benchmark again cool
just like in the previous chart we're
looking at request latency versus
request rate and
again at
and we can see that these are pretty
close so that looked good we can open up
a pull request merge it into the pelican
repo on github and
awesome
now i can move on to what i was supposed
to be doing and actually work on a cache
server
so
the real goal is to add tls support to
our memcache fork
and the primary difference between this
and the ping server is that we have a
much more complicated protocol we have
kind of variable length requests
and
need to kind of focus on that parsing
and being able to respond with actual
meaningful data
so to get started and make sure that the
request parsing and response composition
was all really solid
i actually just took the standard
libraries hash map and
wrapped around it a little bit and
had that stand in for the storage
library so i could get some initial
benchmarking results
uh and when i was confident that this
was looking good
it was then going to be time to
create a better wrapper around the c
storage library i wasn't super happy
with some of the abstractions there
and so i'm gonna wrap that i'm gonna
start including that into my thing super
easy this isn't taking long at all
of course i'd run into issues uh
choosing to use rust
implementations as some of those
foundational libraries left me stuck
when it came to trying to integrate the
storage library
since we want really good observability
and debuggability of these things the
storage library actually ties directly
into the metrics and logging frameworks
and we want that we want to be able to
do these things but
now i have something that's not
compatible in terms of metrics and
logging
um so i had a choice i could rip out the
rust versions of my foundational
libraries go back to using the c
implementations try and create more
ergonomic wrappers around those
libraries or maybe i could figure out
some way to make the c library talk to
the rust metrics and logging
uh it was all getting really super gross
though i spent a lot of time just uh
feeling crushed by this problem and
trying to figure out a good way to move
forward
and ideas that seemed bad at first were
starting to sound better maybe i could
rewrite the storage library in rust
there were a lot of reasons not to do
this um
the storage library essentially winds up
being this place where we run into all
sorts of things that aren't super easy
to do in rust we have self-referential
data structures we've got to
manage our memory allocations to avoid
external fragmentation we've got linked
lists all over the place
which there's a really good
article
series online um
about learning rust with too many linked
lists that's how tough it can be and we
have these pointers all over the place
lots of unsafe code um here there are
dragons
but on the other hand maybe we could
simplify things uh what if we start with
something that's only single threaded so
we don't have to worry about concurrent
access and modification
uh maybe we could implement just the
hash table in c and
uh
hash table and rust and use the c code
to allocate these
big blocks of memory
but this wound up being depressingly
difficult as well
luckily around this time there was a
newer
research storage designed by a phd
student who was working with us and
it just happened that this design was a
lot easier to port to rust
but i took that design and i actually
simplified it even further
i
decided to go with single threaded only
so
i wouldn't have to worry about locking
and concurrency things that i could get
wrong while rust does
enable fearless concurrency
the primitives for doing locking
are actually too big to use in this
context
we're very very uh bite efficient in the
the data structures um so we don't have
much to work with there
um but best of all i wound up being able
to manage all the memory from rust and
not have to do anything terribly exotic
to make this work
so that was cool
of course
rewriting has downsides right
it has a cost
it took me around two months of work to
get a pure rust storage library
implemented
and this was essentially duplicating
efforts that were spent on the design in
the first place
and at the end of that i still don't
even have full feature parity there was
going to be more work to do
but there were also benefits that came
from this instead of integrating the
other storage library we're going to
skip right ahead to this newer design
which has uh benefits for a lot of our
workloads for reasons i'll get into a
little bit later
the rewrite also allowed us to discover
some things about the new storage
library
and come up with some new ideas that we
could integrate into it to help a subset
of workloads
um
and all this really helped get the new
library to be more production ready uh
so
yeah but then there were benefits that
came from rewriting in rust
so i think this quote
from the rustling page really captures
what i experienced russ truly does
empower everyone to build reliable and
efficient software
i was able to confidently write a
storage library that was reliable
had good performance characteristics and
take advantage of the awesome language
features and tools
uh on top of the benefits of uh
yeah
basically um
yao wound up sending me this quote to uh
include and
i just thought this really put things in
a nice way
the rust implementation finally made
pelican modules what they ought to be
but couldn't before
due to limitations of the c language
this feels exactly right and is just as
fast
so i think that's really cool coming
from someone who's been doing
awesome work in c for a very long time
um
to sort of
see no pun intended the benefits of of
rust for this type of
use case
um
i kind of mentioned before rust has
really really awesome tools
there were a couple that i found
particularly helpful during my work
one was cargo bench using criterion
which is really awesome for doing
micro benchmarking and allowing me to
kind of
focus on optimizing the critical
components of the design
and cargo fuzz is also really great this
allowed me to have a lot of confidence
in my protocol library and make sure
that i didn't
just not think of some edge case in in
the protocol parsing fuzzing is an
awesome tool to use for this type of
thing
and both of these together helped me
improve my code and make sure that it
was high performance and reliable
also i thought it was pretty cool how
the trait bounds and generics and all
this
nice stuff about rust allowed me to
express the composability of the
libraries
both the ping server and cache server
are only a couple hundred lines
which is mainly just to handle
initialization
and defining what combination of
components make up the server
so here i'm showing that the
cache server is the combination of this
seg storage library with the memcache
protocols
[Music]
and when we
add a new protocol or if we want to do
yet another storage design it'll be just
as easy to express how those things
compose
and since the we're using these sort of
traits to define
what that interface is what that
contract is between these libraries it
would be very easy to add a new
library protocol and make use of the
rest of the work that i've done
okay so benchmarking this is always fun
uh here we're comparing upstream
memcache with the rust implementation of
pelican seg cache
and
we'll zoom in here
we can see that at the upper end of the
throughputs tested that
the rust implementation actually had
lower latency than memcache
i think that's super cool memcache is
blazingly fast
and uh i
i just think it's neat it's always fun
to win uh performance uh
little um
benchmarking it's it's just a lot of fun
to try and win
um
i mentioned before uh that there were
some benefits that we got specifically
from using this new storage library um
to understand those we first need to
understand how
the two storage libraries differ
um so this is slab storage this is what
you would find in memcache
and this is what i was trying to avoid
writing in rust
you can see that we have
a hash table that's linked lists of of
objects or items
but
uh we have the bulk item storage divided
up into these units called slabs
and each slab holds items up to some
size
so essentially the items are grouped by
their size into these slab classes
if we evict an entire slab all those
items are going to be a similar size
some might be very old and close to
expiration but some might be very new
there are also a whole bunch of other
linked lists that help the server track
like least recently used
all sorts of things
typically we want to operate on slabs
though and evict an entire slab at once
uh under memory pressure
um
and yeah we can see that the the hash
table is is um just a chained uh
linked list
the
uh segment storage library however uses
this
thing called a segment uh instead of a
slab
the big departure here is that instead
of grouping items by their size
we're grouping the items by when they
will expire
this is achieved by using these append
log chunks
and indexing those into these ttl
buckets so we group items with a similar
ttl together
and we just start writing those into a
segment and when that segment fills up
we add another one
we can also see that the hash table
design is a little bit different and
now is using something called bulk
chaining and this helps make it a lot
more efficient by operating on cache
line size chunks
um
so there are a bunch of little hidden
benefits uh to this this storage design
with the items sorted by ttl we're also
able to very efficiently
remove expired items
memcache and twim cash
traditionally use something called lazy
expiration where on the read path the
server needs to check if an item that
it's just found for that key is expired
and if it is it does some cleanup and
returns a cache miss
um memcache newer versions do have a
like background thread that actually
scans through things and can remove uh
expired items and we we want to do this
because those expired items are taking
up memory that could be used for
something else and
under memory pressure we're going to
evict an entire group of items without
necessarily removing just expired ones
so we actually might start to remove
items that aren't expired yet under
memory pressure if we're able to remove
those earlier we're making room for
incoming rights
with the segment storage design we're
able to
very efficiently do this and not need to
actually scan through the items we have
this index
of the segments and when they're going
to expire
so we can just walk each of these
segment chains and if that segment is
expired
expire it just clear it out put it back
into the free list
this also opens up the the path to do
these new eviction strategies we can
actually remove items that are closest
to expiration
whereas typically you might have
something like
slab random or least recently used or
least frequently used
there's also
this sort of merging strategy in uh the
segment storage design where it actually
picks the items from each slab and and
tries to combine these so you have the
items that are going to give you the
highest hit rate
um
so it winds up being
beneficial to a lot of workloads if you
think of things where you have
a variety of ttls
maybe you have some very short-lived
objects and some very long-lived ones
you want to be able to clear out the
things that are expired and you want to
be able to do this efficiently and this
design allows us to do that
we also wind up being a lot more
efficient in terms of the per item
metadata
objects that we have in cash tend to be
very small
we
the
phd student who was working with us
actually did this uh study across these
production cache traces
and there's
we actually published uh kind of
anonymized cache traces um
on github
and there's some analysis there but what
we found is that our item sizes are
actually very small
um
so
like 100 bytes or so
so when you look at something like
memcache which has 56 bytes per item of
metadata that's a lot
the pelican slab implementation
has 39 bytes of metadata per item so a
lot better but still large
this segment storage design uses five
bytes per item on average because it
winds up sharing a lot of this metadata
across a larger collection of items
so yeah the metadata overheads are
pretty
significant
additionally with this storage design it
lends itself very well
to
using persistent memory so intel optane
persistent memory uh
is basically like a very fast ssd um
on your your memory channel um
and you can operate it in this thing
called uh app direct mode so it actually
presents itself like a block device
but it doesn't go through the page cache
of the system at all so um
yeah it winds up being pretty efficient
to you to access it
and we're able to split these things so
the metadata lives in dram still
but the bulk item storage is on
persistent memory
and this helps us really lower the uh
cost per gigabyte for the cash capacity
and we still get about 93 percent of the
performance of dram only
when we're using a four to one read
write synthetic workload so it's pretty
impressive because now we can
consolidate things we can get a lot more
um
pmem into a box um
we can grow what our cache sizes are
basically we're making memory free uh
which is it's pretty cool um
yeah
so just to sort of summarize uh some of
what i talked about
there are next steps uh in terms of
getting this to production need to get
to feature complete which hopefully very
soon
more testing always
do
production canary testing
and then move on to deploying
there's also future work which hopefully
can go in parallel uh to the path to
production
i want to work on multi-threaded
performance
the
threading model that i went with since
the storage library is single threaded
only is
a little bit different and i want to
spend some time optimizing that
general optimization
always want to try and make things
faster
we need a redis replacement as well so
uh looking to do that uh with a pelican
in rust
uh there's iou ring there's all sorts of
like really fun stuff we can play with
rewriting has cost some benefits the
extra time uh could have caused me to
miss a deadline if i was working towards
the deadline um
i was duplicating work that had already
been done so we had to you know pay for
that twice
on the other hand it
is a lot easier to work with an all rust
code base uh no more cmake so nice
see making cargo together is uh not
super fun
um and we were able to get some new
ideas added to this storage library
uh c and rust are both very very fast uh
it does take um
some work to write code that is high
performance but uh with rust we were
able to um match it uh and a lot of this
was
time spent doing like prof uh profiling
and benchmark driven development um so i
found that to be uh very useful while i
was working on this
rust has really awesome tools yay cargo
is a really great build system and after
fighting a bunch with cmake in pelican i
am
even more thankful for cargo
cargo fuzz is an awesome tool it's a
it's a plug-in for cargo um but it's
it's great to have easy access to fuzz
these protocols during development
the uh
cargo bench uh benchmarking micro
benchmarking uh really useful as well
and then things like rust format and
clippy so i could make sure that my code
was nicely formatted and
more idiomatic and had a consistent
style and all that stuff and that made
the code a lot easier to work on and
review
and i am happy to say that pelican has
an exciting future with rust it seems
like we'll be able to migrate the whole
code base to rust
and i think there's a lot of fun work to
come
thanks for coming and listening to the
talk uh thanks to all the folks involved
in putting together this conference
feel free to reach out to me with any
questions
just grab me and come chat
thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you